foreign
[Music]
that he may not bear The Sword in vain
but may use it as the minister of God to
resist evil and defend the good through
Jesus Christ Our Lord
amen
[Music]
foreign
symbol not of judgment but of Justice
not at night but of Mercy
[Music]
endless evenings
with his sword to Justice stop the
growth of iniquity protect the Holy
Church of God and all people of good
will help and defend widows and orphans
restore the things that have gone to
Decay maintain the things that are
restored punish and reform what is amiss
and confirm what is in good order that
doing these things you may be glorious
in all virtue and so Faithfully serve
our Lord Jesus Christ
that you may Reign forever with him in
the life which is to come amen
oh
Lord
[Music]
foreign
Ty and wisdom taken of the Lord's
protection embracing you on every side
thank you
receive this road
may the Lord clothe you with the robe of
righteousness and with the garments of
salvation
thank you
receive this all set under the cross
and remember always that the kingdoms of
this world are become the kingdom of our
God and of his Christ
receive this ring
symbols of kingly dignity and a sign of
the Covenant sworn this day between God
and King
King and people
thank you
receive this cloth that you may hold
Authority with gentleness and Grace
trusting not in your own power but in
the mercy of God
receive the Royal scepter the end sign
of kingly power and justice
and the rod of equity and mercy a symbol
of Covenant and peace
May the spirit of the Lord who anointed
Jesus at his baptism so anoint you this
day that you might exercise Authority
with wisdom and direct your counsels
with grace that by your service and
Ministry to all your people
Justice and mercy may be seen in all the
Earth
foreign
[Applause]
king of kings and Lord of lords bless we
beseech thee this crown
and so sanctify thy servant Charles
upon whose head this day thou Dost place
it for a sign of Royal Majesty that he
may be crowned with thy gracious favor
and filled with abundant grace and all
princely virtues
through him who liveth and reigneth
Supreme Over All Things One God World
Without End
amen
foreign
God Saves The King
[Music]